come on dairy ketchup
which was very both of them he made it
you
hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be a video all about how the flash
has to level up two beats avatar and in
doing so unlock his greatest new ability
there are so many things that the flash
is capable of doing in the comics but
each new season they only do a few of
those so this is going to be all about
the biggest one for this season in the
arc that they're on there is a new round
of the injustice to give away I'm giving
away a copy of the game all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a flash related comment on this video so
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of my
episodes there were a lot of great
powers that he learned during season two
probably the biggest most powerful one
was creating the time remnant to aid him
in his fight against zoom like literally
creating a copy of himself using a form
of time travel then convincing that
other copy to kill himself trying to
destroy that giant device that was going
to crush the multiverse the other big
ones were travelling between worlds that
was like the new big thing but he was
only able to do that with extra
technology from the rest of the team so
sometimes flash is only able to do
things with the help of the entire team
or like with Jay Garrick or the
reverse-flash achieved greater than
normal speed just running normally
and even the Harrison wells reverse
flash helped him build a tachyon device
which made him temporarily faster than
zoom but only by a little bit he was
able to hold on to that and eventually
zoom was able to beat him again till
they got to the finale so really like
the only other big major major new
ability that he learned about was the
Speed Force itself
he doesn't totally understand it but he
was able to become pure speed force
energy and gets sucked up into the Speed
Force crossing that dimensional barrier
that only speedsters can cross the
tradition on the flash thus far the last
couple of seasons has been for him to
learn new abilities based on the things
that he does the challenges that he
faces in previous seasons so like when
he's saving Wally West at the very
beginning of the season he creates those
wind funnels that's like a very
rudimentary ability but when he first
learned about that it was a really big
deal
so with time he gets a lot better at the
really casual powers but then there's
really big problems he faced
is where he has to level up big time so
in the grand tradition of video game
RPGs he has to get XP so that he can
level up throughout each season this
season so far just at the episode 9 he's
seen a couple challenges that he is not
strong enough to face so he is
definitely going to have to unlock a
couple new abilities either by meeting
with other speedsters who have abilities
that he doesn't have or with the help of
team flash learning new science of the
Speed Force that's another thing to
learning about the science of things Jay
Garrick's bringing a more spiritual
approach to things which is kind of max
mercury from the comics so that also
plays into this too but he needs to save
iris from dying at the hands of Savitt
are to feed savatage somehow and then
also we learned about the black flash
that is coming back so effectively his
greatest power this season is going to
be defeating death itself which is
something that goes back all the way to
the wally west era of the flash where
the black flash first debuted so while
these all seem like different problems
defeating death defeating the black
flash who basically is the death of the
speedsters defeating Savitt are saving
iris they all seem like different
problems but really they're all
connected at the end of the day so there
was this very specific progression that
wally west had during the grant morrison
mark millar era right before geoff johns
came on the tile where he learned to
defeat death the black flash during this
arc called the human race so like when
people say that wally west is the
fastest version of the flash he's so
fast that he can run faster than
teleportation he could run to the end of
the universe and back in an instant
that's all from that same black flash
story arc it sort of culminates in the
black flash appearing where he defeats
death after he's done all these great
things but on the way to unlocking that
ability there's a couple other smaller
abilities that he has to unlock first
first he has to get super zen about it
which is where you get to max mercury
but that's kind of like Jay Garrick on
the TV show helping Barry achieve this
Nirvana state where he's capable of
tapping into all of his potential which
is really what's keeping him down right
now he's so bummed out and freaked by
this iris situation that he's sort of
shutting himself off from all
all these possibilities that's one of
the problems of the Barry Allen flash as
well as the Wally West flash in the
comics is that they have infinite
potential but they're only capable of
utilizing all those powers and unlocking
those abilities if their heads are clear
and that is definitely not Barry on the
TV show right now which is why TV show
Wally West is leveling up so much faster
than Barry did because there's nothing
that he is bummed out about he is so
jazzed up that he has to be fourth
powers that's all he's thinking about
getting faster just having fun and in
previous seasons that's usually when
Barry was at his best so this season
before he can unlock that ability outrun
death itself first he has to be able to
clear his head put everything into
perspective and trust the rest of the
team then he'll be able to face the
black flash and that will give him the
ideas he needs for defeating sabotage
because as powerful is the black flash
is he's instant death for any of the
speedsters that he catches saboteur is
still the big boss so he will be around
till the very final episode they did not
say how long the black flash was going
to be around for this season but he just
another step on the way to Barry
learning the solution to Savitt are in a
lot of that goes into the flash family
also leveling up so he also has to learn
to train the team be a good leader which
is something that he's not doing really
well right now so he has to train Wally
he has to train Jesse quick thankfully
we have Jay Garrick around to help him
out with that and they've teased that
there will be other speedsters of the
multiverse that might be able to do
things that Barry can't do that will
give him new ideas and it all goes back
to this really cool Mark Waid arc called
terminal velocity where this is during
the Wally West era remember Barry Allen
isn't around
so Wally learns about the Speed Force
and gets a vision of the future where he
has ultimate power but learns that if he
uses that ultimate power he will have to
leave all the people he loves behind and
join the Speed Force the twist is that
yes to save the love of his life Linda
Park from dying but he has to use this
ultimate power in order to do that
meaning that he would then join the
Speed Force and never be
able to see her again so do you save the
love of your life is it means you'll
never get to see her again that will be
part of the arc this season they only
borrow arcs from the comics they never
do them outright and this is from way
back during Wally West's run but it's
Mark Waid it's probably one of the best
stories of the ever wrote
but it's called terminal velocity so if
you want to read that you can check that
out there's a lot of that stuff that you
will see on the flash season 3 but it
won't be exactly like it is in the
comics so very in unlocking this
greatest power the power to defeat death
might end up never being able to see
iris again but this is only season 3 as
a flash so obviously they're going to
have to take some different route with
it because it's not like Grant Gustin is
no longer going to be on the show in
season 4 it's not going to be Wally's
show they actually address that last
year when people were like hey what's
going to happen when you bring all the
other versions of the flash on and they
were like it's not called flash and
Friends it's called the flash in Barry
Allen will always be the main character
the central storyline even though
they're building out all the other
characters there's a lot of Caitlyn
stuff that's going to be happening in
the back half of the season so we can
talk about that when we get there but
let me know what do you guys think about
the Flash's greatest new power this
season being able to outrun death itself
for those are you asking about the
schedule this week because legends of
tomorrow is on Tuesday night what's
going to happen is I'll try to get all
those videos out by Wednesday like
legends will have to post on Wednesday
because flash will post Tuesday nights I
will try to get arrow out by Wednesday
night but if I don't it'll be a Thursday
morning video so no worries I'll get
everything out but Tuesday to Thursday
will be pretty regular with the DC TV
stuff and then I'll be doing Star Wars
stuff Thursdays and Fridays for the rest
of the year pretty much but I'll explain
that as I post new Star Wars videos so
as long as you have alerts turned on
you'll get all the videos no worries
it'll be awesome but what's going to
happen next is I'll be posting some more
new Star Wars Episode 8 congratulations
to the new injustice to giveaway winner
wildboy 24 just private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video I'll
just announce the winner when I post
that next flash episode video on Tuesday
well you guys wait for that
post you can click here to learn all
about Star Wars Episode eight the last
jeddak and you can click here for the
trailer for the next episode of the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you